your background is across retail you've
been at tesco you've been at walmart
you've also been at halfords most
recently what are the challenges in
terms of doing business as a retailer in
europe is it the economy that worries
you most is it getting online that you
need to be facing i think the most
important thing in retail is to satisfy
your customers and understand the
direction that your customers are going
because that's how you win you win by
satisfying your customers now one of the
things we've been very good at within
domino's is recognizing that customers
want to order more online
that
and this may seem paradoxical the easier
you make it for customers to order pizza
the more pieces they'll order so
online's a great vehicle for for doing
that and the other benefit of online is
it makes it easier for our colleagues
working in the stores because instead of
having to take the information down from
the phone it's straight onto the pc
which goes to the make line so it's much
more efficient and it's more accurate as
well
because you know if somebody's taking
something down on the phone there's
always a danger that actually the pizza
topping won't be quite what the customer
wanted so
it's a win in terms of customer
preference but it's also a win in terms
of operational effectiveness and the
great news is our online customers spend
more money than people who call us so
really it's just
a win in every direction and it's 70 at
the moment orders online yeah where do
you see that going by next year we're
not setting any targets for it because
it's just grown so rapidly what we're
more focused on are the inputs of how we
make it easier for customers to order
online and how we show the broader range
of products that we offer online because
again the great benefit of online is you
can show people meal deals you can show
them the variety of products that we
sell to accompany the pizza and that's a
way of deepening our relationship with
the customer and we can also do things
like retaining last order retaining
credit card so again it's easier for
customers to to buy domino's pizza are
you having to get your own developers in
i mean you've moved to mobile as well
that's about making it easier to have
your own developers what about rival
websites such as justine well
we have we do have a team developers and
we're actually growing our team of
developers
because we're very much focused on
mobile first what we've recognized is
over the course of the last couple of
years whilst online's grown mobile has
just exploded and that's the way that
customers want to order pizza today so
we want to invest in the technology so
our mobile site and our mobile app is
really great for customers it's about
technology it's about satisfying the
consumer what about you as doing
business
you're huge in terms of franchise in the
united kingdom that's your dominant area
at the moment
how has the sentiment been do you feel
consumer sentiment has shifted is the
government doing the right thing in
terms of growth well i'm not going to
comment on what the government are doing
but i i think customers are finding
they've got a little bit more money than
they had this time last year i think
there's a combination of reasons for
that petrol prices are a bit lower uh
inflation's coming down food inflation
certainly coming down so people are
finding they've got a little bit more
money in their pocket they don't feel
confident in the long term of the
economy so they're not necessarily
making big decisions about large-scale
spending but affordable treats but just
what they want and that's what domino's
offers so it's absolutely playing into
our marketplace affordable treats that's
the way to go thank you very much indeed
it's been wonderful speaking to you
david wilde i wish we had more time to
dig in to all things more about those
well meal deals that you can be getting
i'm already getting hungry thinking
about pizza and chicken goujons and all
sorts of things but should really be
focused on parisian food i think